[Music]
the switch may not have a lot of games
in its launch lineup but Nintendo has
said that there are many more in the
works I'm Matt and this is your handheld
console Hybrid GameSpot news update
nintendo president Tetsu Miki Mishima
announced during an earnings briefing
that there are now more than 100 games
in development for the switch that's up
from 80 just a few weeks ago ki Mishima
said that after the company switch
reveal event in January more publishers
contacted Nintendo to talk about making
games for the hybrid console Nintendo of
America president Reggie fils-aime has
said that one of the reasons the Wii U's
struggled was because of extended gaps
between major releases and he said that
Nintendo's goal for the switch is to
release games on a regular basis the
switch releases on March 3rd with a
launch lineup that includes The Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild one to
switch and eight other games at the time
of this recording we'll keep you up to
date if other launch titles are
confirmed so for that and more from the
world of video games stay tuned to game
spot